Movies with shared continuity are all the
rage these days, and you've got one movie
franchise to thank: Iron Man. When the Robert
Downey Jr.-starring action flick debuted in
2008, no one could've predicted the effect
it would have on movies for years afterwards.
Marvel Studios and director Jon Favreau laid
the early groundwork for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe by stuffing in as many Easter eggs
and hidden references as they could, so for
obsessive comic fans, the Iron Man franchise
can be summed up in one word: Marvelous.
The Dude survives
Jeff Bridges' performance as bad guy Obadiah
Stane in the original Iron Man may have been
just fine, but everyone knows it wasn't the
role for which he'll always be known. No,
that distinction belongs to The Dude from
The Big Lebowski. As it turns out, the effects
guys on Iron Man agreed, and added small tributes
to The Dude in Stane's secret computer files,
which feature fine-print dialogue from The
Big Lebowski. Additionally, the weapons Stane
sent to the bad guys went on a ship called
"Lebowski." Those details really tied the
scene together, man.
Urdu, or don't
In the beginning of Iron Man, Tony Stark is
kidnapped by a terrorist group known as The
Ten Rings. Stark's captors discuss their plan,
and their secret partnership with Tony's friend,
Stane, right in front of him, spoiling the
whole movie before it can even really begin…but
only if you speak Urdu, the national language
of Pakistan. Most Western audiences were none
the wiser. Speaking of the Ten Rings…
Ten Rings to rule them all
The first Iron Man flick would eventually
spawn a franchise, but the filmmakers didn't
know that at the time. There was no way to
know when, or if, we'd ever really get to
see longtime magic- ring-wearing Iron Man
villain Mandarin make it to the big screen.
So instead of featuring the bad guy with handfuls
of bling, the filmmakers instead decided to
pay tribute to the Mandarin by naming the
terrorists after him. Which is way less cool
than having a street named after you or something.
That song rings a bell...
Still on the subject of rings, when Tony's
pal Rhodey gets a call from him on his cell
phone, we can hear a very unique ringtone.
That little tune is actually the theme song
from the 1966 Iron Man cartoon. Black Sabbath's
"Iron Man" probably would've been a little
more badass...
...but maybe a little too on-the-nose.
O Captain! My Captain!
Fans saw the first big hints at a larger Marvel
Cinematic Universe when they spotted a familiar
sight on Tony Stark's work bench. Sitting
along with unfinished projects and other junk
is none other than Captain America's famous
patriotic shield. The shield shows up again
in Iron Man 2, while a couple of Captain America
comic books also make an appearance in Howard
Stark's trunk. Both movies predate the legendary
superhero's first cinematic appearance in
2011's Captain America: The First Avenger.
Bambi Arbogast
In the comics, Bambina "Bambi" Arbogast has
been a valued Stark employee for decades.
During her first appearance in 1979, she helps
Iron Man defeat Whirlwind in the middle of
her own job interview, before going on to
play a key role in a number of other storylines.
You can spot Bambi, played by Margy Moore,
in Iron Man 2, when she’s seen working for
Pepper Potts, the new CEO of Stark Industries.
Bambi's also the one who ends up unwittingly
hiring Black Widow, for which we can all be
grateful. She's also heard offscreen in Iron
Man 3, reminding Pepper of her appointment
with ultra-creep Aldrich Killian.
Say hello, Stan
Spotting Stan Lee's cameos has become a favorite
pastime for Marvel Movie fans, and his appearances
in the Iron Man movies are some of the best.
In the first film, he shows up as "Hugh Hefner,"
with a beautiful woman on each arm. In Iron
Man 2, he can be glimpsed as a pretty uncanny
stand-in for legendary talk show host Larry
King. And in Iron Man 3, it's back to the
babes, as Lee pops up for a moment as a very,
uh, enthusiastic beauty pageant judge. Those
were probably all way better for his health
than some of his other Marvel Movie cameos...y'know,
like all those times he almost got killed.
Lady Man-Thing
In Iron Man 3, Ellen Brandt is a war veteran
recruited into Aldrich Killian's army of Extremis
soldiers, and, spoiler alert, she’s killed
in an explosion after attempting to get some
sensitive documents from Tony Stark. It's
a fairly minor role, but hardcore Marvel fans
might have recognized Brandt's name from the
comics, where she's the ex-wife of Ted Sallis,
better known as the Man-Thing. In the original
story, the duplicitous Brandt is actually
responsible for Sallis' swampy transformation,
who attacks and disfigures her in retaliation,
a detail nodded to in the movie with the scars
on her cheek. Most Marvel fans would agree,
though, that Ellen Brandt is a pretty obscure
reference. But it's still probably a good
thing Iron Man 3's screenwriters didn't just
call her Mrs. Man-Thing.
Mapping the future of Marvel
When Tony meets with Nick Fury at the end
of Iron Man 2 to discuss the emerging Avengers
Initiative, viewers can see a map marking
S.H.I.E.L.D.’s locations of interest in
the background. It's the kind of thing you
need to pause and zoom to really get a good
look at, but it's loaded with pretty obvious
references to the comics.
These spots include...
...a location in Africa near the fictional
Wakanda, home of the Black Panther...
...one near Norway where the Tesseract is
found by the Red Skull in Captain America:
The First Avenger...
...another near Greenland where Cap crashes
the Skull's ship…
...and one in New Mexico, where Thor's hammer
had just turned up.
All of this was way back in 2010, before Marvel
really started rolling out its Marvel Cinematic
Universe Phases, so it proves that Marvel’s
planning has been tighter than Black Widow’s
outfit all along.
Hulking out
During the same meeting between Stark and
Fury in Iron Man 2, particularly observant
viewers can see a television in the background,
tuned to a news report being delivered live
from the campus at Culver University. Not
coincidentally, Culver is where the Hulk faced
off against Thunderbolt Ross and Emil Blonsky
in The Incredible Hulk, which puts the events
of that film as happening in the same time
frame as Iron Man 2 in the Marvel Movie timeline...
but still a few years before Tony would deliver
the ol’ Hulkbuster jackhammer to Hulk’s face.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one you
just saw. And leave us a comment to let us
know which hidden Iron Man secret was your
favorite...